Madam speaker Donald Trump a man
a man with whom you have locked horns on
many occasions
is braced for potential charges in a
hush money case that dates back to 2016.
now my question for you is do you really
think that this is the right the looming
indictment from the Manhattan D.A is
this the right vehicle for challenging
the former president or do you think it
will just serve to Rally his base and
improve his competitive chances for the
presidential election next year
well first let me thank you for the
opportunity to be here I love seeing all
these young women in business and in
professions
I frankly would rather be talking about
Samora and Samantha I always wanted to
sing and my children said no Mom
I still want to be a stand-up comedian
so I was listening attentively to
Samantha weren't they both wonderful and
the whole of the whole presentation
today
I think that's a matter for the courts
to the grand jury will vote and decide
on the basis of evidence they have as to
whether there should be a follow-up to
that information so it's not for any of
us to say whether
he should be in date or not it's a basis
of the law and the facts and that's up
to to the court
so that's all I'll say about him because
I as with Samantha
I don't really like talking about him
I'm sure
I'm sure you don't like talking about
him but I'm sure it's also a subject
that you find hard to escape so I'm
afraid I'm going to stay on it for a
little bit longer
I mean one thing I think the audience
would be interested to hear you are at
the Forefront of uh two impeachment
um one defeat against the former
president and your public rebuffs became
you know were sort of you know they even
became memes they were they were sort of
applauded and it seems that you were one
of the few people who were able to Stage
sort of effective opposition to Donald
Trump can you tell us why do you think
that was
why why was it that you were able to
Stage effective opposition
so this is the kind of evening it's
going to be I thought we were going to
talk about how to manage family and
Workforce and we'll get a time and we'll
get over the things right there okay
let's just put it this way
um
our country is a great country the
United States of America and we take
great pride in being a great country our
institutions are strong and we have a
responsibility to our Founders to honor
the vision that they had about a country
based on Dignity and worth of every
person our founding documents did not
necessarily reflect that but they had
the wisdom to make them amendable so in
the course of our history our country
has always become more free whether it
was the abolition of slavery or whether
people black men having the right to
board and then black then all women
having the right to vote and then
respect for marriage equality and the
court of the United States until
the Roe v Wade decision which took us
which took us backward because it was a
diminution of freedom for women in our
country to make their own decisions so
so my
it's about honoring
our country honoring the oath of office
that we take and when I had no choice
but to go forward with uh
actions that you reference is because I
thought
that was justified because that person
was not honoring the oath of office to
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States but there's so much to
be positive about and to look forward to
and not to be dragged back into that I
thought it was most unfortunate that
what's his name put out that thought
that he might be we don't know we don't
know what goes in in the court
the grand jury and so all the attention
went to that when what we have is so so
many uh wonderful opportunities in our
country so many challenges a war for
democracy in Ukraine their democracy the
world's democracy a fight between
democracy and autocracy that we have to
stay focused on and not for political
reasons take uh sides with Putin because
that's what somebody
that you're talking about has um been
doing and and so again it's let me take
us to where we are we're in this Jazz
Center a great Institution for the Arts
I truly believe Emma that the Arts are
going to bring us together as a country
you heard Samantha you heard Samora
whatever your political thinking and the
rest you put that aside you are enjoying
things you're inspired together you
laugh together we laugh together we cry
together we for the moment forget our
differences we have common ground so I
truly believe that the Arts are so to be
here in this great Temple of the Arts of
jazz and to here to performers talk
about their perspective to make us laugh
or enjoy the music and the rest that's a
that's a very positive force I'm happy
that my dear husband Paul is with us
tonight Paul Pelosi
my daughter Alexandra who's in the Arts
who's creative herself and our two
grandsons Paul who's
plays jazz piano he studied at Third
Street Music School that's where he
studies and our and his brother my
grandson Thomas and as much exposure to
the Arts that we give them can give them
is again about finding common ground our
Founders even respected the Arts to this
extent
my one of my favorite quotes is John
Adams wrote a letter to Abigail
and in the letter he says I must study
war and politics
so that our sons can study science and
medicine and
other things like that architecture and
the rest
so that their children are free to study
music
and painting and sculpture even said
embroidery
but you see an ever expanding set of
opportunities for the Next Generation
demonstrated by the Arts an expression
of free Freedom free expression of the
Arts so that is that's what gives me so
much hope because that's so much a part
of who we are as America well that
that's lovely and you're talking about
the Arts as something that brings people
together and
um leaving aside the former president I
think one of the things that you'll be
here
leaving aside is really a good idea
tonight and Beyond
but not leaving aside politics yet
you've been very adept at bringing
people from across the political
Spectrum together you're working with
you Republicans over the years but do
you think that that has become more
difficult I mean I'm you know do I
sometimes think is the next generation
of lawmakers that they aren't as
incentivized as perhaps your generation
were to compromise
well the the
let me just say that
I'll quote Abraham Lincoln
he said public sentiment is everything
with it you can accomplish almost
anything without practically nothing
so when we're talking about trying to
bring people together politically
it hopefully is a reflection of what the
people would like to see
so as we go forward our Focus has to be
on transparency so people know what it
is
bipartisanship as much as as possible
and it's always it has been more of a
challenge lately and accountability to
the people
to the people so I think that the more
people pay attention to what is going on
and how it affects their lives the more
they will be engaged and I hope that
many more women will be engaged because
nothing is more wholesome for the
political process than the participation
in the leadership of women I truly
believe that
and and that holds true in business and
in academic world and all the rest and
uh because we do believe that when women
succeed America succeeds
but here's here's my question and I hate
to sound downbeat but you know we've
seen extreme political polarization
women in politics not just here but
around the world face really virulent
attacks here some of it has more not
just women but it's morphed into
violence generally the sixth your own
husband got attacked why would anyone
become a politician these days well
you're absolutely right one of my goals
when we went as you as was mentioned
there were very few women in Congress
about two dozen out of 435 members of
Congress imagine that I thought what is
this and we made a decision that we're
going to increase the number and we had
maybe a hundred more than we had then
90 some on the Democratic side
Republicans are growing their number and
that's good but we have really they have
I think 20 something or 30 something we
have 90 something I wear this ring made
by women in Afghanistan close to my
heart for all the suffering that they're
are going through with the Taliban I
wear this bracelet about Ukraine
about the Ukraine but it's happening to
women there is so outside the circle of
civilized human behavior rape in front
of your children rape in front of your
parents dismemberment kidnapping of your
children some of those children
thousands of them are probably closer to
Alaska than they are to Ukraine now
because the Russians have taken them in
that's why I was so pleased that the
court of just the international court of
justice has a has a
has indicted Putin because he is
responsible I asked someone with great
familiarity with the Russian
approach to things I said isn't it sad
how these soldiers are become some
brutes how could they be doing this to
these women to these children to these
families how could they be doing this
and the person said make no mistake a
Russian soldier doesn't do anything he
isn't ordered to do this is their policy
to demoralize the country so they might
give up on war because of these rapes
and kidnappings and and murders and the
rest so you write your point that out
and I mentioned Iran as well how women
are suffering in Iran but it's not just
those three places there are three that
we know about and very conspicuously at
this time but throughout the world and
in our own country the lack of respect
for women to say
will decide the size and timing and if
you're even going to have a family
really I mean Paul and I have five
children in six years in one week I hate
them to remind my Archbishop and
and that's lovely for us but who what
politician is supposed to make policy to
tell a family that at their kitchen
table they should be considering what
some politician said rather than what
their hopes dreams and aspirations are
for and if they want to have a family so
I it's all about respect and I think
that um
last week this month last month this
month obviously is what you're the woman
but last week we had the um
International women's day so we had
whole floods of women coming in from all
over the world uh the former president
of Liberia the first woman elected woman
in African history and first in fact the
first Head of State in Africa since
Cleopatra uh imagine the courage and uh
it just we really have to make sure and
shine a bright light on all of the bad
treatment of women throughout the world
and they people that used to ask me I'm
a speaker if you ruled the world what
one thing would you do
the one thing I would do then or now is
if I wrote the world it was the
education of girls and women to make be
able to make their own choices their own
decision that's good for them that's
good for their families their culture
their countries and we just I mean so
say when women succeed whether it's
America or another country or another
culture
the culture succeeds but we have to stop
the thought that they could the Taliban
could do what they're doing to the women
in Afghanistan or the Russians should do
what they're doing in Ukraine and the
leadership in Iran really
poisoning school girls and well you know
what some of it is and it goes beyond
those countries it is related to respect
it's also related to family planning for
those women so that they can be uh in
charge of their own fate well look we're
very lucky to be sitting in a room full
of very impressive female Business
Leaders and I'm sure they'd all be very
interested to hear what lessons they
could learn from you and again one of
the things that you're right you were
known for was your ability to Rally
votes and build build a consensus and
you were a very effective negotiator so
I think
um I think people would like to hear
what your most effect what was the most
expected strategy for you in getting
something for example like the
Affordable Care Act over the line you
know what what what what were your what
were you what was your most effective
tactic well come back to a word that I
have used respect respect for other
people's opinion respect for the that
we'll call our title is representative
and that's our job description too to
represent the people who have sent us to
office uh again as I see all of these
women here in such leadership of women
in the Wall Street Journal that's lovely
congratulations okay
I
see I happen to believe in that one of
my gripes with your person you were
asking that before freedom of the press
is the guardian of our democracy
any attempt to diminish that which was a
priority
and that's that's wrong that's
absolutely wrong because the more people
know the more they weigh in the more our
democracy and my view is protected and
if you don't like the word democracy
freedom freedom freedom for people to be
who they want to be so I want to say
since you're since I had this
opportunity not necessarily an answer
but a response to the question is um
to each of you
just have so much comfort you heard
Samantha so much confidence so much
courage to do what she does stand up in
front of an audience put yourself on the
line there but you do that in different
ways in your in your job and remember
this
you're the only one
the only one in the history of the whole
world that is you the unique authentic
contribution that you make to whatever
you do
whether it's work or family or both or
whatever it is
and how special you are and so you
whatever it is that the combination of
family of environment uh Beyond family
of Education experience whatever it is
it is great because it is you and
because it is different and difference
of opinion is a very big strength that's
why we need more women at the table not
to say that women are better than men
but to say You must you have to have
everyone present at the table whether
it's women or people of color or just
the diversity of our country so I would
say that um
I'm always asked what would you say to
women who might want to be in politics
and it Harkens back to your previous
question which I did not forget and that
was why would a woman want to run for
office when you're subjecting yourself
to this how many times I heard that from
women when I was encouraging them to be
their only authentic original individual
self and make their contribution to
Society to our country to our culture
and they would say you know I could
never put my family through that I have
no children see because I came when my
children were largely in college
Alexandra was going into senior year in
high school but the other four were
already in college but many of I'm
trying to get younger women to be
running
in their 20s and 30s rather 40s for me
and they say I could never subject my
children to that I can't I ran one time
and my my child came home crying from
school because somebody saw an ad on TV
which misrepresented who I am and you
just I I really honestly believe that we
must make an effort because if we reduce
the role of money in politics and
increase the level of Civility in
politics many more women would be
holding office and that would be a good
thing for our country but when they
didn't ask me
what advice do you have to women who
might want to and it just isn't about
politics but it's about everything know
your why I should say them know your why
why do you think you want to undertake
this to be in Congress or to be in the
news business or to be an entertainment
or to be in the corporate world or
academic world why why
should you be the one that has that
particular position at that time
and how if you know your why everything
else is Justified my why as a mother of
five at home was one in five children in
America would go to sleep hungry at
night living in poverty I thought my
this is the greatest country that ever
existed in the history of the world and
one in five children in America goes to
sleep hungry and lives in poverty
my from my own kitchen to the Congress
housewife house speaker and because that
was my motivation and so any of the pain
that goes with it is
weighing of equities about why why
you're there so if you want to do this
know your why that means what is your
vision what is it are you interested in
the climate issue which is a
generational issue
of our time if it's the climate is it
education is it Healthcare is it a
business what is it that is your passion
that you
want to make your contribution and no
the why
the what just be knowledgeable you don't
have to know everything nobody does but
don't think that you know anything less
because you'll wear a tie in a suit even
if you do wear a tie in a suit that's
okay but it is it it isn't the secret
sauce
just know your stuff know why you're
doing this know what it is know how to
get it done so I always say a test of
leadership is what is the vision of that
person
what is a vision of that person what is
the knowledge and judgment they bring to
this debate
of this situation this challenge
are they a strategic thinker do they
know how they're going to get things
done that's all up here
Vision knowledge judgment strategic
thinking and show them what is in your
heart the authentic you we talked about
earlier what you
the sincerity the authenticity of it all
because the that is something that is
appreciated
needed desired and really the most
convincing as to why you should be you
should be the one
it's very exciting I highly recommend it
uh it is um
a lot to be done and the more women at
the table in my view the better that's
good to hear I want to ask a much more
practical
practically for the record I
would I want to know whether you think
or how did the fact of raising five
children help you when it came to your
later career well the thing is is that
any moms who are here or no you are um
you have to be diplomatic it's you know
you're resolving conflict from time to
time you have to be a cook you have to
be a dry a chauffeur you have to be
Quarter Master you have to be referee
you have to be
multitasking you have to be a manager it
is really quite a challenging job to be
a mom and if you happen to be working at
the same time I'm totally in awe of you
because balancing work and home is such
a big thing so what does that mean when
I'm talking to these people well I guess
mostly Emma it was because of my why I
knew why I was there I was there for the
kids but they thought that women
shouldn't be there or one of them who
said she could be here and all that that
was their problem that was not my
problem and now I'm so happy that so
many women and Catherine Clark now and
the leadership and on our side and Patty
Murray on the other side in terms of
leadership in the party but it is um
it's not just about the politics
internally it's the outside nothing that
we do would be possible you talked about
how we passed the Affordable Care Act
it was important for us to get the boat
but we couldn't get the votes just by
talking to the members it was Lincoln
again
the public sentiment
so when when it looked like we weren't
going to pet Mall it never looked like
it to me but when the Press was saying
when the Press was saying
um when they were saying this is
hopeless why don't you give up and
others Even in our own party were saying
you got to shrink it down I was like no
it's not going to happen
so one one confrontation I had um
engagement I had with the Press was um
they said
how are you ever going to get this done
why don't you just give up I said no
this is the challenge at that time of
our generation we are not going to let
this pass for a hundred years presidents
even Teddy Roosevelt Republicans and had
wanted to get this done health care for
as many Americans as possible quality
affordable health care we're not letting
it done
if there's a wall a gate a fence in our
way we will break through the gate if
that doesn't work we're going to climb
over the fence if that doesn't work
we're going to pull vault in if that
doesn't work we're going to parachute in
but we're not going to let anything
stand in the way of getting this done
because it means so much to the American
people to have access to quality
affordable health care so after it was
over they said well which one did you do
I said actually we walk through the gate
we went through the gate not just with
the number of members of Congress it
took to pass the bill
and that was a task
but because of all of the people who
wanted it done thank God for the nuns
who could put off the Bishops and what
they wanted to do to
turn away they wanted the Bishops in in
Bill wanted to
um eliminate Roe v Wade altogether
not just in the bill altogether but the
nuns were there for us not not changing
their value system but understanding
that that wasn't true what they were
trying to do and so anyway thank God for
the nuns I always thank God for the nuns
but anyway just all the people the the
uh
groups that are surround come together
around any diagnosis any disease all the
rest the little lobbyists the children
who came to campaign they helped push up
at the gates so I always say to people
know your power out there the outside
mobilization makes a difference and when
the time came to protect it from assault
you know uh
we had 10 000 events in the country
where people came and told their
personal story of what the legislation
meant to them my child was born with
heart disease heart conditioned million
dollars in bills the first you know
these stories you've heard them from
from people ten thousand stories and
that outside mobilization is what helped
pass the bill and save the legislation
and save millions of lives it was a
great thing and I guess I'll take us
back to where you were in the beginning
so when I go around I'm so proud of our
legislation because this you know this
is a
you have to know how to count and you
had to make sure you have your account
and it's a lot of persuasion or
public sentiment to the rest
so I think it's just such a major
accomplishment I had one of my first
bills in Congress over with 35 years ago
or 34 years ago was about climate and
I'm so proud of him so proud of so much
legislation because I'm a legislator
that's what I love to do
but everybody just goes
they'd make repeat all these gestures
about standing up to what's his name and
it's it's interesting to me because I'm
thinking
I've been there like 30 years before he
even got there passing bills and all
you're talking about is well it's a we
think you saved democracy well hopefully
so we'll see more to come okay look
we've got some questions
[Applause]
we've got some questions from the
audience and two of them are on the
issue of gender pay Equity so um one of
the questions is what do you think is
the appropriate role for the government
to play in solving pay Equity issues but
we had this bill introduced every year
every Congress by Rosa de Laurel the
other day last Friday we celebrated uh
equal pay day that that that was a Day
established by John F Kennedy when he
when we first passed equal pay it didn't
give people equal pay it just said
that's what they should do that would be
the day that until then in March women
were working free
compared to men doing the same job
we have to pass that here's what we have
to do we talked about women and here's
what we have to do equal pay for equal
work
Family and Medical Leave
Child Care affordable quality Child Care
child tax credit and support for home
health care workers because the care
that women and men this helps men too uh
do may not be for a child maybe for a
sibling with a disability or something
it might be for a parent but when you go
to work when you women go to work I want
you to be there
obviously you're always thinking of our
families but you can't be thinking my
child is not in an inadequate Child Care
situation I have to worry about every
phone call it has to be as much as
possible
quality and affordable and that is what
we part of what we try to do uh this
year but we did not complete it and
that's what we have to do because you
know what the workplace benefits from
women being fully there there's a lack
Latin expression Jerry Brown taught me
decades ago Ajay quadrages do what you
are doing
when you're there Focus because those
who will be promoting you and the rest
want to know that you are fully there
and and sometimes you can't be there you
have to have that's why we want Paid
Family and Medical Leave some of you
have that in the private sector most
women and men do not have that in our
country but if we're going to really
have the benefit of the full diversity
of America in our thinking in our
decision making in a reflection of the
needs of the people that we are meeting
we really have to make sure that we're
taking care of the children and the
family as women are in the workforce so
yes I think there is a public role to
pass it we've passed it every Congress
in the house but we haven't been able to
pass it with the 60 vote requirement in
the Senate but public sentiment weighing
in may make that different in the next
Congress so Madam speaker we are more
than out of time but I have two more
questions that I want to put to you
um okay with that
well and send it send any more you have
I mean one of them is you have said
openly that you're backing Biden for
president uh next year what what advice
would you give him or what would you
tell him to change what one thing should
he change or what should he do
differently ahead of that campaign
he's the president of the United States
I don't think he needs any advice for me
but I would give him the same advice I
gave to you
be yourself
the authentic you this is a man with a
great vision for our country Knowledge
from years of service in the Senate vice
president and president of the United
States therefore good judgment about a
direction to take for our country
respectful to the core in terms of
bipartisanship that's how he came up in
politics that's what he knows and of
course
Mr empathy himself Joe Kennedy heart to
heart with the American people so I
think he's a great leader and I would
just say to him what I say to you when
you go out there just be yourself
right and my final question which is a
pretty obvious one but I have to ask it
when is the US going to get its first
female president oh my gosh
oh my gosh
um I always thought that we would have
a female president long before we a
woman president long before we would
have a woman speaker of the house
the Congress of the United States as you
say a couple dozen out of 435
one or two in the Senate at that time
it's
Bastion of male
pecking order for over 200 years you're
going to do it and then I'm doing it
next and I'll do it after you and then
you're gonna and so
um so I always thought all the American
people are so much more ready than this
place this is not breaking the glass
ceiling this is breaking a marble
ceiling
when women when we had more women and
they were encouraging me to run
the shall we say
Hama hummus who were you know thought
they were in the 200 year line said
who said she could run
oh make my day okay
that only encouraged me more uh and then
they said the women want that well one
if they just write a list of things that
they want on a piece of paper and tell
us and then we'll do those things
we've been telling you for a long time
but
um I didn't want anybody to vote for me
because I was a woman and I didn't want
anybody to vote against me because I was
a woman and I think that we will have a
woman president when people see that I
mean we take great I mean I myself took
such great pride in Hillary Clinton one
of the best prepared people to run for
president she she
um all those things a vision knowledge
judgment connection to the people
more more talented than her more
experience than her husband
than George W bush whom I respect and
love but more Talent than that more than
Barack Obama and he would admit it she
had more service more experience in the
rat
don't even let me go into the next one
and
um and now
and in that Arena she would have just
been so fabulous it didn't happen and I
I think um there's still more we have to
do in terms of convincing people that
women a woman could be
a commander-in-chief that was something
I was getting back with Commander G yeah
a woman can be a commander-in-chief
uh that that
um
let's face it I mean I I don't go into
this a whole lot but there's a lot of
misogyny in the whole operation in our
society still we shouldn't be held back
by that as I said earlier that's their
problem but
we have to recognize that there is some
of that so I mean in my case
I got to be speaker because I went out
there and won the election took got the
majority and
they are yeah it's about the election
and that's what a woman president will
be about the election too I hope it was
soon I think it would send a message to
the world uh that
people say
well we have prime minister in England
Prime Minister in in India we had this
maybe that and how come the United
States is so far behind but I think it's
important to consider this
in those countries their parliamentary
governments
what you have to do
is be the leader of your party
and then have your party win in more
seats in Parliament
and it's just a fight within your party
the winning party as to who will be the
leader of the party there then the pro
as and the Prime Minister here it's an
election by everybody in the country for
president of the United States that is a
really different challenge so we
shouldn't be diminishing ourselves by
saying we never did that but we should
just just do it
I just have to leave you with one
thought because this is my
sort of
tattoo
when you go into that Arena all of you
I'm talking into running into office and
ignoring the bad stuff the other side
might do in terms of that
remember your why am I why are the
children as I said the um
Teddy Roosevelt notice I'm not Teddy
Roosevelt Lincoln to Republican
president they a Teddy Roosevelt said
that um
um
he talked about the arena if you have
don't know his speech you should read
his speech it's so fabulous about the
arena you're in the arena you're no
longer a spectator you're an actor you
have to get the job done
so I say to the women in my case the
children side of things so when you're
in the arena you have to prepare to take
a punch
it's rough it's rough in the arena
and you have to be prepared to throw a
punch
for the children